on va essayer de deviner quelle rumeur
appartient à telle ou telle personne
regarder derrière moyens tableau assez
bien ça marche je serais sorti j'aurais
du téléphone rose à votre avis tient
delphine vais commencer par vous je
serais sorti avec mon propre fils je
vous le dis à vous parce que sais je
sais que c'est pas vous je serais sorti
avec mon propre fils ben c'est isabelle
non non non non non ce qui m'a dit
sophie way sophie non mais c'est dingue
parce qu'en fait c'est jettent rumeurs
attention évènement dans les moeurs et
fo mais j'étais en vacances je suis plus
ou d'ailleurs du reste avec mes enfants
et mon fils qui a 20 ans parce qu'il va
avoir 21 ans mais à l'époque il avait
mis je crois 18 ou 19 ans on a été pris
en photo ensemble les genres ça a été
titré dans un tabloïd en fait une sorte
de torches le torchon absolue genre
sophie koch s'éclate en vacances à elle
aime les petits jeunes enfin même si tu
veux c'est très jeune par mois que c'est
mon fou
c'est dingue
attention était le temple les rumeurs de
nos amis ici mais je rappelle des
rumeurs c'est punir alors à votre avis
j'aurais fait oui j'aurais fait du
téléphone rose c'est qui à votre avis
delphine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi j'ai absolument alors quand
j'étais le jeune il n'y avait pas de
portable et donc pour téléphoner on
téléphonait à des cabines à la pièce ou
à cartes et moi je jouais au foot très
régulièrement le soir et on sortait
toujours à la même heure après la douche
23h30 et j'avais une copine à l'époque
n'est pas régulière que j'essayais
vraiment de séduire chaque fin de match
et je l'appelais de la cabine
téléphonique alors c'était un peu coquin
peu grivois etc et j'avais pas remarqué
que derrière moi il y avait un gars avec
qui jouer au foot tu m'aimais pas
j'avais piqué sa place et il observait
il avait fait venir le gardien et tous
les deux ont fait courir la rumeur que
j'avais des rendez-vous à 23h38 nord de
téléphone rose et ça m'a poursuivie
pendant des années les amis des amis à
fêter fourie bien
j'aurais été là sex friend michel sardou
alors michel sardou c'est déjà une
époque on a trouvé cet échange
obtiendrait la belle isabelle
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des rumeurs
bah oui mais en irlande c'est un oui
c'était en 81 cents
c'était un beau trou duc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est en trois ans 87 dans le connemara
avec toute l'équipe de michel denisot
pour une mouture moi j'étais pour vsd et
je suivais tous les gars véronneau il y
avait bal à toute une aot s'échapper
toute une série urgences de golf
et puis il y avait donc michel sardou
qui arrivait de miami très triste parce
que le mari de mireille darc qui était
mort le deuxième est donc on était là
ensemble et puis moi j'étais chargé de
le suivre pour vsd banque je le suivais
tout le temps et la journaliste local
évident mais qui sait cette fille est
quelqu'un le dit je crois que c'est la
femme de michel sardou et tous les
journalistes locaux ont écrit la femme
de michel sardou ce qui fait pendant
toutes ces jours où on était inconnu les
jambes ni moins que tu peux nous
organiser un rendez vous avec michel
sardou est bien évidemment bout d'un
moment je me suis dit un truc qui cloche
et j'ai démenti mais encore temps en
temps et un truc qui ressort quand il a
permis la mise en branle compris pardon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s'emballer serait bien mais alors je
vais vous dire ça m'aurait pas déplu 1 a
passé une annonce regarder la télé non
maintenant à l'esma mais michel si tu
veux jamais trop tard oui bah si c'est
trop tard et très amoureux de maria oui
et puis voilà j'ai vraiment quelqu'un
mais voilà ça veut dire quoi ça à la
boutique et perd et c'est bon c'est
alors on va regarder le tableau encore
poursuivre un peu alors j'aurais eu une
aventure avec le père fouras sabathia
jeu remporté 6 et est maintenant
annoncée lé fils de réflexion
delphine sûr mais alors qu'est-ce qui
est mignon sega fort boyard tout le
monde enfin les fans essaye de savoir
quels personnages et à quel personnage
des liens de parenté et où je me suis
dit voilà je vous dis ça
et effectivement le père fouras dans les
petits teasers ils montent parfois qu'il
est un peu amoureux d'intel et surtout
de blanche parce que blanche attire les
convoitises de tous les personnages du
sport et on le comprend on comprendre sa
balle mais dites moi il a quel âge le
vrai le vos personnages mii patients
très très très nord et ben oui je sais
mais la date l'interprète ça me ferait
comme le père noël un dans le principe
arrive au bal des
villes y croyez
ce qui lève très haut la jambe parce que
si je crois que c'est un ancien
bernard moi j'ai appris quelque chose
j'essaie de l'âme et encaissant le coup
non j'ai a cédé à part dont j'ai essayé
de la mettre aux questions grosse tête
mais ça ne marche pas le père fouras et
celui qui construit toutes les toutes
les épreuves dans koh lanta
[Musique]
la bénisse effectivement
[Rires]
leur couple avec un animateur tv ça
c'est guy novès et stevie mois ah ben je
sais pas moi avec
ça c'est une légende urbaine louis au
début c'est des rumeurs je rappelle
qu'ils étaient en cours les gens
pensaient que j'étais en couple avec
laurent ruquier alors que pas du tout
oui oui c'est vrai j'étais à dormir avec
lui on a bien dormi ensemble mais
s'habille tout était habillée enfin
voilà chacun de son côté du l'insee
attend la réponse de kiabi ou pas moi
c'est en caleçon et comment tu vas
dormir avec laurent ruquier en fait mais
ils sont tous ces débats c'était au tout
début c'est
ça s'est passé comment oui au début
c'est en fait savait pas d'appartement à
paris j'étais un peu bloqué sur paris je
sais même pas où aller et puis je
voilà j'ai appris
je reviens c'est toi la rumeur
[Rires]
expliquait laurent ruquier ya qu'une
chambre n'a non c'est non il m'a proposé
là
quelqu'un de très correct oui saint jean
que le malawi m'a proposé la chambre
d'amis mais c'est moi qui veux pas non
j'avais pas dormir dans la chambre
d'amis et on pouvait parler on s'amusait
bien dire enfin bien sûr
s'est jamais conformé on va pas assister
là dessus c'est bizarre tonneins xiii
s'est passé je serai influenceurs beauté
sur tik tok
bah oui c'est toi alors en fait il ya
plein de gens qui m'ont écrit qu'ils ont
dit ah j'adore ce que vous faites sur
tik tok je suis fan de cette idole j'ai
reçu des mails ou je vous suis tous les
jours son titre sauf que j'ai pas tic
toc
et en fait j'ai compris aujourd'hui
pourquoi j'ai retrouvé une vidéo du mec
c'est un mec qui me ressemble en fait je
crois qu'on a une image du maquis
[Musique]
la paix
et aux meilleurs
à l'instant
[Applaudissements]
il est charmant il est moins vraie
influence en beauté ah oui c'est la même
sans lunettes très bien il a besoin
allez on poursuit j'aurais eu une
aventure avec ça c'est déjà fait voyons
je serais sorti avec l'un des trente
deux fils de cassel
non ouais fiona c'est un gars qui a
circulé à la suite d'une émission à
laquelle j'ai participé il ya quelques
années et à l'époque c'était guillaume
genton le producteur de cette émission
ça faisait beaucoup de moi de ma
situation amoureuse il me faisait
faisait chauffer tous les mecs qui
passait dans l'émission et notamment le
fisc est à 10 et julien quitter
quelqu'un m'a arrêté deux mois et qui
dit qui est venu un jour avec un faux
bouquet de fleurs parce qu'on a
évidemment pas de budget chez nrj 12 et
en me déclarant sa flamme validé imagine
soit guillaume genton ou l'autre
producteur t-bone après ça attire que
les évidemment sur les réseaux sociaux
il faut reconnaître quand même que les
enfants de cassady sont beaux et ce
serait très beau gars c'est surtout ce
très beau c'est la belgique est à moga
si vous tous vous dans la famille et ils
sont beaux mais calmez vous
allez on a fait croire que j'étais gay
j'aurais bien dis moi c'est mon nom non
rebbouh c'est bernard émond non mais y'a
plus crémeux non non non y'a pas moi moi
je sais j'en arrive là c'est pas toi
raymond alors c'est pas moi bon ben on
sait pas qui c'était
mon cas mais non
[Applaudissements]
que
depuis toujours j'ai que des copains
voilà un moule toutes mes femmes on
pensait que j'étais avec l'un d'eux
alors ça ça a changé de femmes mais j'ai
parlé de copains et parce qu'il est tout
on pensé que j'étais gay à part hors
[Applaudissements]
surveille tout ça se passe bien turon
bien le rap c'est dans trois 3 minutes
16 en trois mois
je vais bien effectueront bien d'accord
alors c'est important c'est important si
c
est mon chien
c'est moi
il a mon labrador t'imagines mon
labrador alors c'est vrai que je l'aimé
profondément
[Rires]
non j'ai aimé ce chien vraiment j'en
parlais tout le temps il était tout le
temps avec moi sur tous les plateaux les
amener sur les plateaux de télévision
pendant 15 16 ans line et à vos vidéos
gags tout ça bref et et je ne sais pas
pourquoi dans deux journaux ces sorties
est horrible genre zoophiles carrément
bernard montiel a plus que de l'amour
pour son chien ce serait même physique
mais ça comment on peut dire des trucs
horribles pareil évidemment que j'aime
les animaux enfin enfin voilà ça c'est
une grosse méchanceté ah bah oui aux
aliments pour bébés enfin bon il me
manque beaucoup
non favaro farouk c'était la route des
phares ou
avait mis dedans bernard montiel et
farouk el had et des gens qui
connaissaient farocki vous connaissais
pas vous c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces chiffres
je serai le fils du président du psg
cette anecdote folle parce que c'est à
l'époque où je jouais au paris saint
germain il avait construit en dessous de
la tribune des nouveaux vestiaires et
nouvelle une nouvelle salle de muscu
pour les jeunes du centre de formation
et moi je sors de l'entraînement et mon
père il m'avait emmené à l'entraînement
et au même moment que je sors moi de
l'entraînement mon papa sort des
toilettes et il ya le président du paris
saint germain qui sort du nouveau centre
d'entraînement et les deux se passe
devant mon père passe devant le
président du paris saint germain qui
était laurent perpère je suis très bien
à gilles il venait juste d'être nommé il
ya une équipe de stade 2 qui sont devant
les grilles pour filmer et en direct à
stade 2 et oui tout de suite maintenant
le nouveau président du paris saint
germain qui sortent des vestiaires mon
père il se met devant laurent perpère on
voit plus laurent perpère on voit mieux
faire prendre une semaine tout le monde
est rude pour père étaient présents du
paris saint-germain j'aimerais en
profiter pendant une semaine
et en a pas profité les mecs m'ont dit
si tu montres ou des voitures à l'époque
c'était un constructeur allemand qui
était sponsor du psg si tu vendes soir
des voitures ouais je veux bien mais
puisque mon père et les présidents y
avait pas internet on remet tout dans le
contexte et à par internet et pas les
réseaux sociaux vont prendre une semaine
je me suis fait un qui jusque là on m'a
dit mais c'est pas ton père en fait le
président grave c'est au tournant
tribune